apple c'est la solution que je souhaite
à trouver pour préserver la relation
accessible donc au vert séparé de sa
compagne il lui a fallu faire des choix
après quelques discussions la garde
alternée ou cm2 s'est imposée
d'elle-même
jean-claude l'envisagé pas un seul
instant devoir s'atteler détient délicat
alors j'ai pas l'impression que manon
soit absente dans ce cas d'epalinges ai
pas à me concentrer à être le bon père
le jour où il faut quoi bon c'est vrai
que partage aussi plus mon quotidien
elle a fait 200 plus de fouet de
nouveaux amis pour sa fille jean claude
a trouvé une maison rue de l'école il a
fallu composer avec son caissier
d'interdire jongler avec l'emploi du
temps la décision de la garde a été
prise à l'amiable en famille avec comme
seule priorité
l'équilibré de ma vie j -l ce soit d un
parfum pragmatique est chez nous et sata
convenu toi et fais chier pas plus chez
papa qu'elle est chez maman partage des
semaines d l'étranger limitée des frais
le couple ne trouve pour le moment à la
garde alternée que des avantages à peine
quelques points 15 au 20 septembre
j'ai plus de temps pour mon fils j'ai
plus de temps pour ma vie de couple que
je suis en train de refaire et puis
finalement ben je profite que des bons
moments de manon pour cette famille qui
a trouvé un terrain d'entente
la garde alternée est une réussite mais
ils sont encore rares dans ce cas celui
pour cent dix ans s'il ya ou non moi
mais la fête des pères chez maman